more than 2 million refugees have fled
that war in ukraine in the last two
weeks alone and some of them have
families back in the united states but
according to the state department
ukrainians are only being considered for
resettlement in america if the countries
they fled into are also unsafe we spoke
to one ukrainian american who flew all
the way to poland from san francisco
hoping to fly back with two teenage
relatives
and learned here that that's not allowed
as reports spread that war was coming to
the ukrainian city of odessa marina
safee told her 19-year-old sister
victoria and 16-year-old nephew ilya
about the 622 train to poland and told
them to run they were able to jump on a
train and stay
tight yes like that there were a lot of
people who were trying to get out the
moment the teens were safely on board
safety and her husband ran as well
boarding the next flight from california
to poland and leaving behind their two
children the youngest just two years old
the direction were that as soon as you
get out of the train you are not going
to any volunteers you sit there and you
wait 10 days 20 days until your auntie
comes to pick you up they reunited five
days ago on that now famous train
platform in shemesh thinking the hard
part was over
but that's where the family's luck ran
out when we went to the american embassy
they just turned us away they have no
sympathy no understanding even when i
say i'm american citizen i want to take
my kids despite reassurance from the u.s
government we're going to keep providing
security assistance economic assistance
and humanitarian assistance and special
protections for ukrainians already
living in the u.s
the state department so far hasn't
announced any exceptions for those
fleeing the war even if their closest
family relatives are american
safety was stunned when the leaders of
the country right
tell you we stand with you we support
you this is not actual support actual
support is when you help me to bring my
family they don't have any place to go
they have to go with me to make matters
worse victoria lost her passport in the
rush out of odessa poland let her in
without even checking the documents they
allow people in without even birth
certificate because there is a humanity
and why america cannot be human the
situation has left her in what feels
like an impossible no man's land she
can't leave her family in ukraine but
she also needs to get back to her
children in america how long
can you stay in this limbo it's
extremely hard i'm a fighter i'm going
to be fighting for them i will not send
them back i will never send them back
but stuck in poland and prohibited for
now from entering the u.s
there's only one place these teenagers
really want to be it's the more she
wants to go home
right now no one else in safee's family
is able to get out of ukraine to be with
those kids you're looking at their
ilia's mother that safety's other sister
is a police officer must stay and their
grandmother is not well enough to travel
so she's stuck there as well we reached
out to safety's congressman that's
representative eric swalwell whose
office did tell us that they are going
to be contacting her and will help in
whatever way they can remains to be seen
what that way will be but for now i'll
send it back to you guys in new york
as we see these families in ukraine
let's keep in mind that there's no
bigger family than the human race this
is not a ukrainian issue this is a
humanitarian issue and that's just one
family story that's right that's right
tony thank you so much we'll check back
in with you a little bit later